Can we please stop shitting on motherhood and children
and start placing that blame on our culture where it belongs?
I'm so tired of all the negative rhetoric around motherhood and babies.
Like, oh,
just wait until you never sleep again.
Oh, my god,
don't expect anything from your husband.
You're gonna be so alone.
And just wait till the postpartum blues hit in and, oh, wait,
you're gonna be so sleep deprived
you might actually harm your children.
Guys, just to be clear,
that is not motherhood, and that is not babies and children.
That is our culture 110,000%.
The amount of negative advice that I got from moms
while I was pregnant was just absurd.
Like, literally obscene.
And all it did was make you fear motherhood.
Like, I remember thinking,
I'm one of those that does not do well off no sleep.
And I was like, oh,
my god. Like,
what if I hurt my baby? What if I get really depressed
because I am so incredibly freaking tired?
Everyone's like, you won't sleep again for the next three years.
You're gonna go stir crazy.
The only adult you're gonna talk to is Miss Rachel on your TV.
I've said this before and I'm gonna say it again.
Motherhood was never meant to be that difficult.
Yes, it's hard,
it's tough, it is not an easy job.
I'm not at all gonna degrade what I do at home every single day.
But back in the day,
We weren't expected to do all the things that stay at home moms do now.
You weren't expected to be a full time freaking maid,
a full time chef, a full time home educator,
a full time chauffeur. Back in the day,
people had communes, okay?
It takes a village to raise a child.
That is because women stayed home while the men went to work,
and they stayed home and raised the children.
And if you were a postpartum mom,
your prime job was literally
to sit there and make sure that that child had nutrients
and was being nursed every day
that it was held, when it was cried.
You slept when the baby slept,
even if you had other children,
because other moms, other aunts,
other neighbors, other sisters,
other nieces would all come in,
and if you needed a nap, they're like,
let me help with the baby.
If the village needed to be clean or the hut needed to be clean,
they had other women cleaning and cooking.
Your job was literally to provide nutrients to your child.
My god, my child was chewing on my little suction cup,
and I found it.
Okay? The phenomenon of isolating mothers
did not happen until the turn of the century,
really, closer to 1950s,
when they started giving home loans to vets,
and they started getting wives and moving outside of the city,
and some even, you know,
conquering the west, like California and Texas.
And you Were pretty much there was no homesteading or village.
It was just you and your family
trying to get farmland from the government,
move away from the city, try to become self sufficient,
you know, all the things.
But historically, women with children still lived with their families
or with their husbands families.
They still had post menopausal women that would take care of them.
They would let them bleed in a tent when they were on their periods.
They weren't expected to work and do all the crazy things.
Motherhood was honored, your cycle was honored,
childbearing was honored. And yes,
it's difficult, but it was not what it is now.
And you see it nowadays even more with, like,
military wives. I have a lot of friends that are military wives,
and they become very isolated because why
they're moving from fort to fort or base to base with their husbands,
and all they have are other women to rely on.
And at the end of the day,
making friends is hard. Unless you come up with a mommy and me group,
you're stuck at home. There's days I'm stuck at home alone.
Now, this is not because I'm not close with my family,
but mainly, like,
my husband works out of state and he's a farmer,
so I'm home a lot, kind of doing just the single parent role,
and he provides phenomenally for us.
Um,
but this is kind of the state of our journey that We're in right now,
um, until,
you know, he grows the business more,
which he's going to. He's killing it right now.
But my point is, that's the only reason I'm home alone,
Manning the ship by myself,
doing everything. Mom,
dad role. It's cooking,
it's cleaning, it's the education,
it's. I'm the family doctor.
Like, everything is by myself.
And I am tired, I am sleep deprived
and I have a teething toddler in there.
And unfortunately, my family can't even help that much
because modern feminism, boss,
babe culture. My parents are still working,
my mother is still working,
she can't retire because of inflation,
um, and bidonomics.
There's just so much that goes into this.
But stop degrading motherhood.
Like, that's the reason that we're in this place,
because it's not. You choosing to have a child
doesn't mean that you are automatically gonna be sleep deprived
or alone. We choose to be alone most times.
Most, like,
millennials don't even want their freaking mother's input
or help from their in laws.
Like,
sometimes I have to go outside of myself to break that
and break that pattern and actually call my in laws and say,
you know what? I need help today.
I don't wanna be a helicopter mom.
Like, take him,
do whatever you want with him,
I need to sleep, I need to nap.
But we don't do that anymore.
We don't rely on others. We all have this modern day feminism.
I'm an Independent. I can do whatever I want.
But then at the same time,
we sit on TikTok
and we bitch all day long about how hard it is to be a freaking mom,
when in reality, it's not the mom or the motherhood
or the child who's teething and not letting you sleep.
It's the fact that our culture sucks.
So as an example, I went to a birthday party, slash, like, um,
baby shower for someone that I didn't even know,
but they were passing around these cards saying,
give your advice to your. To the moms.
Now, I live down here on the border,
all right, by Mexico,
so I'm. I'm.
I am a minority, um,
and she was Hispanic.
And all the cards from the white moms were just trash.
It was like, don't expect to sleep for the next three years.
Don't expect any help from your husband. Um,
one and done. You know,
get a vasectomy after he's had to get your tubes tied.
Like, it was terrible shit advice from our white culture.
And then, like,
all the Hispanic advice, and I'm looking at them like,
she's not gonna have to worry about that because she's Latina.
Like, she has her mom helping her.
She has her abuela, she has her nieces,
her sabrinas, her primos.
Like, she has all the.
The support because their culture kept to that.
And the only ones that don't hear an El Paso, honestly,
just because they have been
I can't use that word on TikTok.
Um, they have been, um.
Their culture has kind of been washed out by our crap American culture.
Okay, they.
We also did it with their food.
So I was laughing because I knew that, like,
she had her family support and her parents and, like,
all this advice they gave was crap.
Like, I gave real advice,
you know, co sleeping. Awesome.
Do it. That's how you get the most sleep.
Um, I gave some other advice that I probably can't say on TikTok
because I'll get banned again.
But my point is,
while I am sucking out my wrinkles, you see him?
Stop blaming children and motherhood.
Like, if we just finally wrap our brains around that,
what we have done in the last hundred,
maybe 200 years is so nuanced,
including diet, child rearing, everything, marriage,
everything is so nuanced that we were Guinea pigs
and we are now the result
and the long term effects
of what we started doing at the turn of the century. And.
And we sat here
and we thought that we were gonna be better than our parents
and our grandparents and our great grandparents,
and we were gonna fight biology
that has existed for thousands of years,
and it's not true. So, yeah,
the minute we just start wrapping our brains around that,
things have to change. And guess what?
You see a lot of it right now.
You see a lot of Millennial families like my family,
that are, like,
moving out with their families and family compounds,
they're getting with their best friends and their brothers
and they're building houses next to each other
and they're homesteading. And we're going back to milling our own grain
and cooking right for our family
and not doing seed oils and not doing all the nuance crap
that they told us was so good for us for years.
We're getting back into the village mentality of child raising,
and that is freaking beautiful.
So anyway, that is my, um,
10 minute rant,
because both babies actually somehow got to sleep the same time,
so I had a moment to myself.
Love y'all.